il y aura donc oui liste lutte ouvrière
dans les yvelines pour faire entendre
comme ils disent la voix des
travailleurs mais au niveau local pour
le scrutin du 15 mars prochain la
formation a choisi de se représenter aux
clayes-sous-bois une troisième
candidature après 2008 et 2014 déjà
menées à l'époque par olivier augustin
employé chez renault flins on défend des
idées
l'idée que dans cette société là il ya
vraiment deux camps et qu'on pourra pas
s'en sortir sans mener la guerre contre
ceux aujourd'hui qui nous amène nous
c'est surtout cette idée là qu'on veut
faire passer
on a réussi à monter donc encore cette
fois ci d'une liste lutte ouvrière donc
sur les clayes-sous-bois qui rassemble
33 candidats et candidates des cheminots
que les agents hospitaliers des agents
de service bout des ouvriers du bâtiment
quoi bref qui est vraiment à l'image de
toute la population ouvrière aux
clayes-sous-bois lutte ouvrière
également représenté attrape la liste
sera menée par patrick planque ouvriers
de maintenance à la sncf
autour de lui des cheminots du personnel
de santé ou encore des agents de
nettoyage
cette ville est
est intéressante parce que effectivement
c'est une ville ouvrière avec une longue
histoire de lutte
quand même qui a appartenu longtemps au
pc mais en tout cas avec plus de trois
mille cheminots qui habitait dans cette
ville il ya quelques années encore du
coup sa marque réellement les esprits et
quand on parle aujourd'hui de recréer un
parti un parti d'une travailleurs en
parti ouvrier qui organiserait les
choses dans les quartiers qui
organiserait les choses dans la ville
est bien dans les plus anciens il ya une
petite étoile
six autres candidats ont déposé leur
liste dans les yvelines à poissy
conflans sainte honorine aubergenville
carrières sous poissy mantes la jolie et
aux mureaux